He's known as one of the nicest guys in Hollywood,...
...but Johnny Depp has excelled himself.
The star donned his famous Jack Sparrow pirate costume in Australia...
...to pay a visit to a children's hospital.
Yes!
Complete with the character's trademark dreadlocks and eyeliner...
...and customary quirky British accent, Depp posed for selfies with beaming children.
Now, if there's other people in it, why do you call it a selfie?
He also recorded a special message for the patients.
I've had a wonderful time.
I've had a fantastic time meeting all the kids and everyone and the parents...
...and the people and all that.
And I stole a lot of things.
And I want to salute you, all of you, for your bravery and your courage.